I'm more confident after today's
arguments and I was going in that the
individual mandate is in trouble but
today was day two of the oral arguments
over the Obamacare legislation and I
went into the court today expecting a
major showdown and I was not
disappointed I mean this was a
constitutional Thunderdome today major
major questions about the role of
government in our lives the powers that
government has what sort of limits the
Constitution places on the federal
government and limits versus the powers
given to States these things were
debated thoroughly fully and I have to
say it was a very bad day for the
federal government today the Solicitor
General was asked directly what is the
constitutional limiting principle under
the Commerce Clause power since you're
claiming that the government now has and
he was not able to give a good answer
and he came back to this repeatedly well
that the health care is unique art is a
unique market something unique about
this you know we're all need health care
at some point and the justices by my
count at least four and maybe five of
the justices were not persuaded by this
they wanted they said you know you that
can apply to the market for burials
everybody they also said everybody needs
food you know we've talked a lot about
the broccoli mandate can the government
force you to buy broccoli well broccoli
came up repeatedly today and Justice
Scalia said well you know we all need
food why can't the government force you
to buy broccoli and then the government
the Solicitor General today had no good
answer to that now there may be a good
answer out there somewhere in the briefs
or somewhere else and Justice Kennedy
and Chief Justice Roberts may find it
but they did not hear it today today's
arguments and the outcome of them have
the potential to be one of the most
support and if not the most important
Supreme Court decision in in a hundred
years certainly since the New Deal when
there was a and that's basically the
last time when there was such a dramatic
showdown between a sitting president and
legislation so closely associated with a
sitting president talking about FDR and
anise and the Supreme Court and the
legal challenge to it I think that the
individual mandate suffered a big defeat
today in court and i think that there's
good reason now to believe i'm more
confident after today's arguments and i
was going in that the individual mandate
is in trouble i'm not willing to say
that it's going down because i don't
think we can read especially Chief
Justice Roberts but it's absolutely in
real trouble and this is going to be a
close
decide a decision and it could go either
way at this point and that's something
you remember Nancy Pelosi saying you
know are you serious when people first
raised the idea that it was there a
constitutional you know issue involved
in this and she said are you serious you
know just dismissed it out of hand well
you cannot dismiss this this case you
cannot dismiss these arguments and if
the Supreme Court strikes down the
individual mandate I mean this is this
is will be a profound statement to not
just this administration but future
administration's future congresses that
the Constitution imposes substantive
limits on what you can do what aspects
of American life you can regulate in my
view that's that's perhaps long overdue
but regardless if that happens that that
is that is a fundamentally important
decision for all merit